das schreckliche zugunglück war gar
nicht fünf menschen sind tot darunter
zwei mütter die genau davor vor dem tod
aus der ukraine geflüchtet waren ihre
kinder jetzt halbwaisen was wer ist
schuld an diesem unglück heute hat die
staatsanwaltschaft münchen
ermittlungsverfahren gegen drei personen
wegen des anfangsverdachts der
fahrlässigen tötung eingeleitet
garmisch-patenkirchen trauert um die
opfer des zugunglücks bei dem
ökumenischen gottesdienst wird in vier
getöteten frauen und dem getöteten 13
jährigen gedacht andere des gedenkens
fragen sich die bekannten der opfer nach
dem warum
unglaubliches schicksal was gott so
etwas zu
[Musik]
unter den opfern alexandra c sie
flüchtet mit ihren sohn vor dem krieg
genau karine sie stirbt in einer
regionalbahn in bayern die gedanken der
menschen in der region sind bei dem
siebeneinhalbjährigen sohn der seine
mutter verlor
versucht für den jungen der zeit wann
halbwaise von der bahn die er versichert
ist
einen schädel zu gebrauchen es ist einem
die berechtigung ist da derweil läuft
die suche nach der unglücksursache
experten gehen momentan von einem defekt
am gleisbett aus dafür sprechen die
bilder vom unfallort und dass die bahn
sanierungsarbeiten an dem betroffenen
gleisabschnitt durchführen wollte für
den 25 juni sei eine gleis lage
berichtigung geplant gewesen und danach
schienen erneuerung gegen drei
verantwortliche mitarbeiter der bahn ist
jetzt ein ermittlungsverfahren
eingeleitet worden gegen den strecken
verantwortlichen den lokführer und den
fahrdienstleiter
dieses
dramatische ereignis wird umfassend
untersucht und aufgeklärt werden und
erst am ende wenn man weiß was genau die
ursache war kann man schlüsse daraus
ziehen klar ist dass dieses restlos
aufgeklärt und aufgearbeitet wird
hätte der unfall verhindert werden
können wenn die schienen früher
repariert worden wären das wäre ein
schlimmes untersuchungsergebnis denn die
bahn sieht sanierungsbedarf im gesamten
schienennetz teilweise sei dieses marode
und überlastet drohen also weitere
tödliche unglück wie das von garmisch
partenkirchen